Here are the best viral
products I tested in 2021.
Let's start with brows.
The Huda Beauty #BombBrows
Microshade Brow Pencil
has this incredibly thin point
that makes it so easy to
make hairlike strokes.
It is a little fragile,
so be careful with how
much pressure you're using,
but I love this pencil.
If you struggle with using
pencils to fill in your brows,
I highly recommend this
Madluvv Brow Stamp Kit.
You apply one of the stencils to your brow
and stamp the brow color on to fill.
It makes doing your
brows so fast and easy,
and you don't have to worry about
having two different brow shapes.
Now my favorite brow-setting products.
Everyone went nuts for
the ABH Brow Freeze,
and so did I.
It gives your brows that
fluffy, laminated look
and keeps the hair
locked in place all day.
But I recently tried the ELF Brow Lift,
and I swear it works exactly the same.
It also came out with
this special applicator
that really lets you
press those hairs down.
Moving on to complexion products,
the Fenty Beauty Eaze
Drop Blurring Skin Tint
is so natural and beautiful on the skin.
The coverage is minimal
but very buildable.
The L'Oréal True Match Nude
Hyaluronic Tinted Serum
is another great option.
It evens out the skin
and gives you a very
glowy, hydrated finish.
Plus you get the added
benefits of hyaluronic acid.
The Pseudo Labs PHreckles Kit
is definitely the best product
I've ever used for creating faux freckles.
You use the freckle liquid,
which has this little round brush in it
and this little toothpick-looking thing
to flick the liquid onto your face,
and it gives you these very
natural-looking freckles.
This Givenchy Prisme Libre Loose Powder
is a huge splurge item
that actually lived up to the hype.
The colors all blend into
one translucent shade
that really brightens up the under-eyes
and sets the face without
leaving you feeling dry.
It makes the skin looks so smooth.
Next, my favorite makeup product, blush.
I tried so many different kinds this year.
I think my favorite was definitely
the Melt Cosmetics Cream Blushlight.
This formula is pigmented
and blended like a dream.
It layered over powder
really, really nicely.
The Em Cosmetics So Soft blush
is also a cream blush,
but in a stick form.
This one is very user-friendly.
Because it is so soft
and easy to blend out,
you don't have to worry
about overdoing it.
The Made by Mitchell Blursh Liquid Blusher
is probably the best liquid-blush formula
I've ever tried.
I applied this over my
already-set foundation,
and it still blended out so well
without removing any product underneath,
and the pigment is so intense.
Now on to bronzer.
Just like the blush,
Em Cosmetics So Soft Multi Faceplay
is creamy and easy to use.
The shade I got was more
of a contour color for me,
but there are some warmer
shades for bronzing.
The ELF Putty Bronzer is
another amazing bronzer,
and an affordable one.
The blendability of
this bronzer is unreal.
It has this really interesting formula
that goes from a cream to
more of a powder finish.
It's so easy to work with.
Next, we have some really
interesting eye products.
These Chameleon Flakes
from Kaima Cosmetics
are like little shavings of
pigment that shift color.
They definitely have a
bit of a learning curve,
but once you get it, they
look amazing on the eyes.
This product is technically
a multiuse product,
but I'm putting it here.
This is the Danessa
Myricks Beauty Colorfix
eye, cheek, and lip cream pigment.
The pigment in these is no joke.
A little goes such a long way.
And the fact that you can use them
as so many different
things, under-eye corrector,
blush, eyeliner, lipstick, eye shadow,
is definitely a plus.
And finally, a few of the
best lip products I tried.
If you want that full-coverage,
transfer-proof lip,
definitely check out
the NYX Lip Lingerie XXL
matte liquid lipsticks.
One thin layer is all you need,
and once they dry down,
they're not moving.
The Milani Color Fetish matte lipstick
is also very pigmented
and wears really nicely.
These aren't as matte as you would think,
and they still have that comfortable slip
that you'd get from a regular lipstick.